Two three.
Yeah,
my name on it.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the Monday
morning podcast for August 12th,
2013. How you doing? How'd you like
that intro? Wasn't that pretty cool?
That was actually, you probably go on
the whole, who were those fine singers?
Okay.
Jesus Christ. That was the, that just
human beings doing that by themselves.
No auto tune was Kanye West.
Dot.
In there with a leather fucking skirt
on singing about getting his Dick Schaap
despite the fact he just
had a baby daughter. Um,
uh, fuck. One of my ears is
ringing. I hate when this happens.
Does anybody else have hearing damage?
Yeah,
come on. Stop ringing. Um,
every once in a while one
of my ears just goes, Woo.
Okay.
And then it fucking,
you know,
like some heavy metal singer from
fucking decades ago. Like say,
remember your childhood, you acid
wash jeans. Anyways, that was the, uh,
members of a truth, that salvage
company. Um, I got to know those guys.
Uh Oh, it's getting no, through
Busan. I met Deb drama, Bill Smith.
I was out on a drunken night and he
came over to me and he said, hey, hey,
my name is bill also. Why don't you
tone it down? You freckled cunt.
And I had to respect
them. No, I'm kidding. Um,
they have a new album out called a pick
me up that's available on iTunes and a
new single called Appalachian hilltop.
If you actually like human beings,
if you like, if you'd like, yeah,
if you'd like some sort of heartbeat in
like your music at this point, you know,
not saying that you guys out
there on your designer drugs,
eating each other's faces,
watching some guy with a mouse head and
your glow sticks is not a good time.
You know, if I got sucked into heavy
metal, you know, when I, when I was, uh,
coming up in the 80s,
if I was coming up now,
I would fucking by probably be there.
I definitely would be.
I'd sit dead jumping up and down in
unison is that guy played his stereo,
some club. Um, am I doing the
thing that all old people do?
I get fearful and I'm just
trashing all the new stuff.
I was reading something recently when, um,
when airplanes first came out, actually,
believe it or not,
people sometimes I do read and I was
reading this book about when airplanes
first came out and, uh, this guy was
pitching, we basically all we had,
we had like, we had the army
and the navy and that was it.
And this somebody in
one of those branches,
cause I already fucking forget because
every other word reminds me of something
in my life. And I just
start thinking, you know,
Tom Sawyer got on a boat. I
remember I got on a boat. Yeah.
Maybe that digging in
that Kid's pool party.
And I flipped over and I got underneath
and then my eyes keep going and like six
pages go by and I have no
fucking idea what I read. Um,
so I don't,
can't remember the guy's fucking name.
And I think we just had an army and a navy
at this point.
And this was, I know in the, in the
teens, maybe the twenties of law,
I'll just say last century as opposed
to people try to confuse you and go the
20th century,
you know,
the 18th century, 18 hundreds was
the 19th century. You got to do that.
Fucking carry the one shit last century.
All right.
And he, he basically said to the army
and the navy, he was like, hey man,
like these planes, man, they're
going to like change shit. And like,
I don't know if you guys are
going to be ready for it man.
And all the old guard were like,
Rah Rah,
go fuck yourself if you got them Kleenex
and your dental floss and your little
lawn mower motor that you have in that
thing and engine, right? Fuck you.
What are you going to do to make my
iron sides over here? So he's like,
well listen man, like I don't really
want to take it to that level,
but why don't you pull one of
your bad ass boats out? Damn.
We'll bring her fucking planes over. See
what happens. So they said, all right,
so this sitting there laughing at him
and shit and they got this fucking thing
that's like sixth,
I don't know.
It's really thick and it's really
hard to sick and they keep an AP
little lawnmower fucking engines and they
sank the fucker in like 12 minutes and
there was actually navy admirals crying.
Yeah,
they couldn't believe it.
Um,
they were out of a fucking
job. They thought. So anyways,
is that what I'm doing when
it comes to like dubstep boy,
that shit like I guess I should be
into it. I Dunno. I like these guys.
Truth and salvage company. I, I,
they have my stamp of approval.
If it means anything.
I saw them when they opened a for the
black Crowes where the fuck were we?
Somewhere in La.
I don't know what.
So I don't know if you like that kind
of music. Give these guys a shot.
If you're into other kinds of music,
just keep listening to that shit.
I don't give a fuck, but I don't need to
hear your fucking reviews of it. Okay.
I'm just suggesting this is our
defenses being on Twitter makes you,
because no matter what you suggest,
you could just say something simply,
simply like, you know, ice cream is
delicious and then you will curry flavor.
You get it all that she will,
you know,
the fucking someones inverted it,
and he's got to deal
with these fucking cunts
then as it's coming from a
con. All right, so whatever.
I feel bad cause I only mentioned Bill
Smith and a band and I probably just
fucking created a bunch of
infighting in their van. Right?
If you're in a fucking band, you got to
be riding around in an event, don't you?
Isn't that how it works? Um,
anyways, let's plow ahead.
Shall we people I am,
I am still here in New Orleans.
As you can tell the quality of
this podcast, the audio, the audio,
at the very least, okay. Is A,
is much better than last week's because
the lovely Nia I actually sent out my
bow is strip or the chord, whatever
the fuck you call it. And um,
so at least she can hear me.
At least you can hear the attempts,
you can hear the big swing and a miss.
And I gotta tell you something.
I actually was actually rooting for
Alex Rodrigues this week. You know,
I really was not because I liked the
guy that cause I'm all of a sudden a
fucking Yankee Fan.
The bed bath and beyond of the
major league baseball community.
Um, I just really yeah, the
uniforms look like towels.
Very nice towels,
but towels nonetheless.
Okay.
I'm sorry I'm drinking some water here.
I burned my tongue.
Isn't that the fucking worst? I
actually, I ordered room service.
I got a grilled cheese and tomato
soup as old people do. And um,
I uncovered the tomato soup,
which was way too fucking hot and
I had the grilled cheese there.
So I'm an American.
I can't just eat the grilled cheese.
I've got to take that grilled cheese and
I got a Dunkin into the fucking piping
hot tomato soup, so I stick it in my
fucking pie hole. Big Bite of that shit.
It's a lava hot. So what
do I do? I use my brain,
my brain says, hey bill, that's like a,
you're not gonna have much tongue left
if we don't do something about this.
How about grabbing some Colt?
So my right hand was like, oh,
I got this and reached over to
that nice ice cold glass of water.
But the,
the,
they had plastic on top of its cellophane
so it wouldn't spill when the lovely
brought it up to the room. So
my right hand's like, you know,
this ain't going to fucking work.
And then the rest of my body went
into panic mode and I went boom.
And I just spit out,
spit it out instantly.
I thought it was actually a smart move,
but I immediately started laughing
thinking that that would have been the
greatest vine ever or
one of a nice one anyways
is a bill burr each burns
tongue is that it was, you know,
can you actually do a vine where
it's actually just one thing.
It's not a bunch of Shit splice together.
Actually,
I know what the fuck I'm talking about.
I'm just saying it burned my
God damn tongue. All right.
People just trying to tell the story.
A fucking puke that thing out.
Like, like you have a see a snake when
it's in the middle of eating and all of a
sudden you walk up to it and it's like,
oh fuck, I think I'm going to get eaten.
And then it's just sorta opens his
mouth in that Yak comes out of it.
And then the snakes sitting
there like, now what's up?
Huh? You want to do this? Um,
basically walking up to a snake while
it's eating is like what happened to me
when I went to that buffalo bills
game with my patriots hat on.
And they waited till I was taking a
piss. All right. With my Johnson out.
And then they pushed me in the back.
Cause that's what they do up there
in the city of lights.
Other than eating the fucking
wings and losing Superbowls,
they wait til you get your
dick out in Buffalo. Don't
ever forget that. All right?
So when you go up there to the falls
over there in Niagara, all right?
And all of a sudden you get that sensation
that you've gotta take a piss looking
at all those.
Just know,
just know that the great grandson of
Joe [inaudible] or whatever the fuck you
said his name.
Okay.
You know Fred smartlist junior,
my fucking pushed you in the back
is all I'm saying. All right.
Not trying to cause any static
with that great city.
Okay.
Formerly great city, that city that will
rise again like Cleveland, like Detroit,
like de Moines. Um, that'd be tell
you guys how much I love those cities.
I like, I'm a fan of architecture and
when I go there I always just look at,
I'm like this eventually this fucking
place is going to blow up in a good way.
I mean that in a hip hop kind of way.
Look at me,
look at me straddling the
fence of my whiteness. Um,
this is another sign that I'm getting old.
I have a real problem with that new
Kanye West album that, you know,
cause I want to settle down and be a
fucking parrot and all that type of shit.
So I look up to other people that finally
fucking do it and I'm thinking, Whoa,
is this guy going to,
you know,
it's easy going to be changed
somehow with this new fucking album.
And it's just still talking about
losing his diamond ring in some girls
snatched.
Isn't that what it's all about?
I Dunno.
Sometimes I glad I looked the way I look
and I was never able to enter the club
scene other than to be ushered
quickly back out the side door.
Um, anyways, what are
we talking about here?
This is the Monday morning podcast and um,
IOP having a nice August. The summer's
coming to a close, but you know,
this is the golden age of global
warming waters. A little warmer.
It's just starting to tickle your toes,
but you don't have to worry about getting
eaten by a shark yet and you fucking
living room. So, you know, I think
you might get an extra three weeks,
three weeks of the summer.
Okay.
You know, what's the greatest is the
football season is starting and you know,
I've become a huge college
football fan over the is. And a,
I actually realized that my
Lsu Tigers, my adopted. Okay.
Before anybody bet rouge
gets mad at me. Like, man,
you ain't from prepare you I from air.
Nope.
They Call Him York targeted our targets.
Um,
cause that's what everyone in
the south sounds like to me.
Okay.
All right.
Whether you do or you don't,
you do in between ringing ears.
Evidently they're starting their season
and their guests who they're playing,
guess who's back in my life.
They're playing. They're playing
those jackasses on the kickoff day.
I know Alabama's playing somebody else.
Uh, I don't know who the fuck their plan.
Alabama. Can you believe those? You
see what those cuts did this week?
You see what they did to fuck in the
Aggies, you know that came from them.
That horse shit about
Johnny Manzel sign and Shit.
You know that came from an Alabama
booster. You know what did you know it,
you know why? You know, I think it came
from them cause they're fucking scared.
They're scared that skin that's skinny
motherfucker is going to run all around
the field like the white Michael Vick.
Alright.
And he's going to fucking beat their
ass as again. I actually saw the replay,
the end of the game last year,
where a Jesus Christ,
you never saw sadder looking faces
when they cut to the stands after that
interception, right down there in the
end zone. Tremendous. Oh, look at that.
I'm looking out on the Mississippi
River that goes a paddle boat.
Whether it was Tom Sawyer once,
you know,
way back in the day when food was fresh
and everybody was dropping the n word,
every other word, right? We will
exterminate the Indians. Oh,
what a beautiful piece of history.
Um,
all right, what am I doing here? Is it
time to do a little, a little advertising?
Would you say? Well, I don't give a shit.
I'm in control of this thing, right?
I'm running, I'm running this motherfucker
fucker. All right. Dollar Shave club,
everybody. You know, there are so many
things in this world that irritate me.
Canadians, fans, script tattoos.
People will get to the front of the
line and shoot the shit with the ticket
agent rather than just getting their
fucking id out and getting on the Goddamn
plane. I was so many things late
in the world that irritate you.
Why would you ant let raisers add to it?
What I'm trying to say is
stop milking your razor blade.
Okay. I know you're, I know
what the brand name razors.
I was this to be a bad week or read
and come on bill. Pull it together.
It's the first quarter. All right. We
already burned a timeout. Fucking ghetto.
The Mirror. Um, I know
with brand name razors,
you're used to paying outrageous prices
and exhausting those rages razors until
they start to look like rusty soda
cans. Let it go. It's time to move on.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month.
Never think about it again.
They send a pack every
month for just a few bucks.
You can change your blades every week.
Trust me. Your face will love you for it.
I'm, I'm using it right now. You
should do it too if you want to.
I'm not trying to force you
to do anything. All right.
You want to keep shaving with that,
that rusty thank. Go ahead, do it.
It's your face. Uh, joined dollar
Shave Club, shave time, shave money.
You get it.
Go to dollar shave club.com/bird that's
dollar shave club.com/burr or click on
the dollar shave
banner@thepodcastpagebillbird.com
and also,
I, you like me, do you like watching TV?
But you want to watch it on your
own damn time. Hulu plus everybody.
It's the best way to do it.
I'm sure you've tried hulu.com,
but I want to tell you about Hulu
plus the next level, the first class,
if you will, who will plus let you
watch thousands of hit shows anytime,
anywhere streaming on your TV or go
with you on your smartphone or tablet.
Why stand in line or ride a train and
just stare at your feet or maybe chat up
some girl and get laid.
Why would you want to do that when you
can be watching your favorite shows on
Hulu. Plus, Hulu plus is a great way
to binge watch your favorite shows.
Hulu plus has tons of episodes from
great comedies like SNL community,
modern family, South Park, family guy, and
thousands of other shows, and guess what?
Hulu plus,
it's only seven 99 a month.
That's seven 99 for all the
shows and movies you can watch.
Catch up on current shows, binge on an
old favorite or catch a great movie.
You can do it all.
Where on Hulu plus right now you can try
Hulu plus for a couple of weeks free on
me when you go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] dot com and you click on the
Hulu plus better or go to
Hulu plus.com/bill please
make sure you use Hulu
plus.com/bills you get an extended free
trial and so they know that I sent you.
It helps us keep the lights on
and gives you a better deal.
One more time for the extended free trial.
Hulu plus.com/bill Oh,
look at me starting off slow coming back,
killing those reads.
Um, alright. What the hell am I?
Let's get back to the podcast.
Got a big couple of weeks coming up
everybody and I want to thank everyone who
went out and bought tickets for the show.
I'm doing co headlining with Brian Regan,
who's Kitten kitten who I'm
opening for the guy. Um,
we're doing a show at COBB's comedy club.
It is all sold out and uh,
the money is going to charity and a,
I can't wait to do a Brian's Ben,
one of the,
uh, I dunno how long you
been doing this. 21 years.
I've been a huge fan of that guy since
the first time I saw him and I've never
got to work with them in this capacity.
So I'm really,
really excited about doing this.
And uh,
I'm actually also really interested to
see how his fans react to me and my filth.
Um, all right, so that's,
that's on August 27th and then August
28th. All things. Comedy Network,
the network that I've
started with a Almay,
the daily show's Al Madrigal,
Emmy Award winning.
Al Madrigal you like that?
I have a friend that won an Emmy.
I knew I used no al Madrigal
when it was owl al Madrigal.
Now when I talked to him,
I have to go, excuse me,
Emmy Award winning Al Madrigal.
Yeah, me, him and some other guys.
We all started this comedy network
called all things comedy. Um,
just cause you know we saw podcast
blowing up in artists always create scenes
and then they never end up with the money.
The business man comes in and a,
we own your podcast and we get all
the money and you get great exposure.
Go Fuck Yourself, have fun and
behind the podcast music on VH one.
So we created like a co op
where everybody owns this shit.
We all come together like a cap side
ship trying to keep the sharks away until
the fucking coast guard comes.
It's called all things comedy
and we're doing a live show,
our official kickoff of this wonderful
network that I'm going to begin blogging
on. I've already written a blog. Um,
and we're going to get that up
hopefully sometime this week. And, uh,
that's going to be an August
on August 28th at Largo.
It's going to be featuring as many
people from the, uh, the all things,
comedy family. Al's going to
be there. I'm going to be,
their top pop is going to be there.
I believe Tom Segora, we've got a,
and those who aren't are
going to try and make videos.
It's going to be a great night.
All right.
It's at Largo on La Cienega
here in Los Angeles,
August 28th. All right. Back
to the God damn podcast.
Um, so anyways, uh,
the past couple of weeks I've been
talking about the food down here in New
Orleans saying how delicious slash
unhealthy it is and how you can't find
fucking Kale, excuse me, as a drink,
more cold water for my fucking
scalded tongue, blah. Um,
I actually bought a juicer this week to
somehow combat all the fried food that
I've been eating. And a, I started
drinking that shit that, that guy and uh,
uh, fat dead and kind of sick,
whatever the fuck is called,
fat sick and nearly dead.
Okay.
Just sick, fatty with dead
fucking something, whatever. Um,
I've been drinking that Shit, man. I
gotta tell you something that's delicious.
Not only is delicious,
you crave it after awhile and uh,
okay.
Yeah, I think I dropped like four
or five pounds. Good pounds too.
You know the flabby once I was joking
on Twitter saying how I was in,
I was in buttoned down shirt shape
and I actually want to get into like,
I want to be in shitting
down no shirt on shape.
Okay.
I Dunno what, I know bill Cosby
did a bit on this, but he's,
so what the fuck happens
when you sit down?
You stand up and look
sideways and Mariella Guy,
you know what? That is a bad,
dare I say it's kind of cue shows
that I like the occasional snickers.
Right. And you should, they're pitching
it yourself like you're in an old,
old school, special k commercial
going on. Right. That's not that bad.
It's not that bad.
Then you just sit down and like three
of shit just lands on your thighs.
You know,
for the life of me, I can't,
what is, what happens?
The hip bones move up to your fucking
man tits and everything just gets blown
out. I have no idea. But sitting down
without a shirt on, you know, that's,
that's the truth moment of your fucking
physique that you're going to see all
day. Stop standing up, sucking
in your gut. All right?
You want to see,
you want to see the damage you've done.
Maybe you're not ready for
all right.
This is like the ring. When you
looked at that fucking chick's face,
you judges opens up and you land
in a fucking walk in closet.
Oh my God. I don't know what happened
to me. I'm not even that bad a shape.
So I said, fuck this.
I got a juicer. And um,
I just did a quick gig up in Chicago,
came right back, this private thing. Um,
so I don't know. I ate halfway decent
up there. I did find a Vegan restaurant,
but then of course they had
had some Chicago Pizza. Um,
yeah.
So now I came back and I had my little
fucking grilled cheese sandwich and
tomato soup.
So now my body is starting
to pull me back to the,
to the bay,
the dark side.
And that's what I've really learned
about trying to stay in shape.
It's all about keeping your
brain out in front of your body.
Okay.
Keeping your fucking wits about you.
Like this shit, it's like food. You don't,
when they need to say food is a drug,
I didn't believe him, but I,
I'm totally convinced of it now.
It's like when you're reading bad,
when you just go on like a three month
bender have just eaten bad and in your
head like,
Oh God,
I got to stop by of fucking cheeseburger
and you just keep going and then that
makes you want cookies
and all that type of shit.
It's the food equivalent to like locking
yourself in a Roman just free basic for
three months. That's what you
doing. So when I tried to do,
when I'm eating,
eating bad like this,
I just talked to a buddy of mine outside
of the business who's trying to lose
some fucking wait.
I was trying to tell him that like you
gotta keep your head out in front of it
and just go like, I want that,
but I'm going to eat this.
Even the in,
in,
in that moment when you're looking at
that apple as opposed to that fucking
glorious, whatever
you're looking at, right?
Toasted roast beef and cheese with the
fucking pickles and the chips and all
that. The last thing your
body's like, that's fine.
Just what the fuck I want.
And you got to reach for that apple.
You got to fucking hit that,
that crack pipe instead.
And I'm telling you the second you
get two, three bites in, you're like,
oh thank God, thank God I did that.
Then you fight cause so from what I've,
what I've read the braid little,
I've read your body is
actually craving nutrition.
You know,
that's why we eat Chinese food.
Like fucking 35 minutes later,
you're hungry again because your
body's still craving nutrition.
There wasn't like a fucking
ounce of it in that shit,
at the risk of getting sued by that
entire fucking continent of China
country. Go Fuck Yourself. Um,
so that's what I would say
if you could try to do,
that's what I'm trying to do as I'm
trying to keep my head out in front of us.
So I got that grilled cheese sandwich
and I got to tomato soup and I said,
all right, I gotta get back on
the fucking Green Gumbo here is,
I'm calling it because I'm in
New Orleans and uh, that's it.
I'm back on that shit for the last two
tomorrow morning to wake up and make
another one. Bingo. Bango
I'm trying to do two a day.
Jewson and then one day having
the fucking, uh, you know,
a healthy dinner and then I'd go
on the treadmill for a half hour.
There's no fucking way you're not going
to drop away. All right, so there you go.
So stop doing those stupid ass fad diets.
EA.
It's the fucking cornflakes died.
Oh, I do it. He could plagues.
They can eat as much as I wanted.
That bullshit veggie eventually.
Okay.
You don't really, I think the really,
it really is, is not even like,
it's not even the fucking diet. It's
the, once you get to your weight,
what do you do then? You know,
once you get down to your weight,
at some point you're going
to be looking around.
It's like he got out of jail and
there's some ice cream right over there.
You're an adult.
You don't have to go more.
Right? That's how you become
a fat fuck as an adult.
There's no one to say you had enough
cookies. So on you fair enough.
Boots put on a condom.
It's all on you.
You gotta be your own fucking parent
until you get a lady and your life.
And then she starts
fucking nagging at you.
[inaudible] get out the rug ass.
Fuck you lady.
Where did you become so angry?
Um,
so that would be my advice when
you're just on, if right now,
if you listen to this shit and
you're on a bad fucking road,
I'm telling you one of these days in
the future, you're going to wake up,
you're going to be sitting
down on the side of your bed,
you're going to glance it to a mirror and
you're going to be like, what the fuck?
What have I done to myself?
You just stand up real quick.
You can try to suck it in and try
to deny the truth that you just saw.
Hear that?
That's the steam engine coming back
on the fucking racist genocide.
One Oh one. Um, the fuck am I to, yeah,
just make yourself eat an apple
or just eat a fucking salad.
You gotta you gotta turn that
you've got to turn the boat around.
Yeah.
That's what I'm trying to do.
I've got to do what I fucking went back
up to like almost a buck 90 and now back
down to like the mid one seventies.
I got to the fucking worst.
Just trying to lose like 15
pounds is the fucking worst.
I can't imagine people who got, uh,
got to lose more than that. So, uh,
you know, I don't, I don't know how this
became more of a weight loss podcast. Um,
but I think it's working enough. This guy
actually sent me a letter. He said, uh,
podcast success story,
Dear Wilbur,
you sir are a god amongst men.
Ah, Jesus, I wish that was true.
He goes, I used to be a depressed
piece of shit. You're a,
your typical, the world is
against me. Nobody likes me.
Nobody wants me fucking moron.
That's who I was.
But your advice on stepping back and
making fun of every negative annotation I
have. Is that a word? Did he write that
d type that correctly?
Or My homeboy annotation,
I dunno not to make you depressed
again. I don't know how to spell. Um,
he goes, I have fucking change
my life. I'm 80 pounds lighter.
I got a great girl and I've gotten
two count them two promotions.
You're a comedian.
You're not obligated to be Oprah.
Amaury but you still make a
difference. Thank you, sir,
for knocking me back into cohesion. Uh,
you probably make 20 times more than me.
I doubt that sir, with the
two big promotions there. Um,
but I know,
but I owe you a drink next time I see you.
And if you're in Canada or being town,
you stay classy, sir. Wow, that's great.
Good for you sir. Look at
that. He turned it around
somehow. My negative, whatever
the fuck my shaming, my fat shame.
My for shame has been working.
Um,
all right, enough about that
shit. So that's what I'm
doing. I'm drinking the, I'm,
I'm doing that fat,
sick and nearly dead juicing thing
and it's like all green stuff.
It's Kale, celery, a couple of
handfuls of parsley, cucumber,
Zucchini, and then alignment to
take the bitterness out. And uh,
I get tell you it's fucking delicious.
I love it.
And um,
I dunno,
I think I'm going to incorporate
this in every couple of months.
Just go back to that.
Well,
just juice for like four or five days
just so I stay out in front of it just so
I don't have to have sit down one
day and have that fucking beach ball.
I got a thing on my button down shirts.
It's the one, two third button down.
When that button's starts to look like
it's doing the iron cross between both
sides of my shirt. That's an
amazing guy. He fucking jerk off.
All right.
And then what happens is they lay off
the beer and then I just start slamming
whiskey.
Like that's my initial when I've,
we've begun our initial
defendant until our dieting is,
I go from drinking Pale Ales to whiskey.
I really am a freckled
mess. All right. Um,
so anyways, I had a lot
of downtime last week. Um,
I wasn't working. I had a couple of
days off from my episode of Glee.
Um, it's really long episode. You, I can't
believe how long the film in this book.
You know,
I guess this is how they do it over there.
I'm to sell a hell of a budget.
MMM.
I got into one on Netflix and I
started watching a Ken Burns the war.
I know. I'm like, that came out like five,
six years ago. If you haven't seen it,
if you like me and you
late to the party dude,
like that's my
recommendation for the week.
It's a seven potter on World War II.
Each one's is about an
hour and 50 minutes long.
And I know that sounds like I just told
you to watch every episode of lost.
Um,
just,
it's effortless to watch this thing other
than the amount of times you have to
hit pause and go, Jesus Christ,
I haven't done shit with my life.
That's what, that's what it
makes me feel like. I can't,
okay.
I can't even begin to, uh, you
gotta you just gotta watch it.
You've got to watch it.
And what's great is it really
ties the whole war together.
Where for me, I've always seen
like, they'll always do stuff on it,
on the history channel that there'll be
talking about the war in the Pacific or
they'll talk about the blitzkrieg or
they'll talk about d day and occasionally
they'll talk about northern Africa,
but this thing kind of
goes in chronological order
of the whole damn thing.
And um,
okay.
It's, it's, I don't know. I can't
explain it. It would be like,
what the fuck was that movie that they
showed and it showed it backwards and the
guy tattooed shit on his arm.
I can't remember what the fuck it was.
It's like finally seeing
that thing going forwards.
Um,
it's just,
it's unfucking real what?
Jesus, I'm too stupid to fucking just
go. Just go watch the God damn thing.
Why don't you people 17 years old lying
saying they're 18 and just going out on
the front lines and just listening
to these fucking Bob's whistle again,
seeing all your friends
getting blown up and just,
just having to resign to fate while this
one's either going to hit me over it.
It isn't, and I'm still going to
be fucking shooting at these guys.
MMM.
They, that the stories that
they see, they talk about that,
that the guys who were flying over on
the bombardiers before they had the
escorts and Shit and you had to do
25 fucking missions before, you know,
you had basically completed
your obligation and nobody
had ever made it past 14.
It's a fucking suicide mission. And, uh,
they had a guy who actually survived
the ship because he was in that little
fucking skylight at
the bottom of the plane
and he got shot the fucking arm and
went through him and killed one of his
buddies and I don't he,
and then he still went back,
flew another one and got shot again.
And that's the thing that I,
that basically saved him was
because he kept getting shot
okay.
That he wasn't physically well enough to
go back up in the God damn plane again.
And you know,
and I actually have the fucking
nerve to be afraid of flying.
I'm landing in fucking El Paso,
Texas going, oh Geez, oh gee,
there's nobody shooting at us.
I never felt like such a fucking
pussy in my life till, I mean,
I feel bad enough when I watched
like a UFC event, you know,
or I watched one of those, uh, the one
of those shows about going to prison,
you know,
I,
I watched the training for UFC and I
would be like that the I three times
kicking that,
that heavy bag with my leg,
it would be all bruised up
and I'd be like, it stinks.
I want to get out of here.
It just, can I be the guy
who washes the tee shirts?
Can I mop up the mat? The Mat that
you guys wrestle on, you know?
Okay.
I Dunno. He just, whatever.
Ken Burns the war and he's done a whole
bunch of documentaries and now he's
doing one right now that is, uh,
that's about the Vietnam War.
Now I'm all paranoid that I
said his name wrong. You know,
all of a sudden that sounded like some guy
in Espn, but that's Candy Maine, right?
Yeah. Ken Birch. There we go. All right.
I've got the right guy. All right.
He's the one writing
one right now. He's, uh,
making one right now on the Vietnam War,
which I'm definitely gonna Watch.
You know, he already made one
on the civil war, so I'm like,
I'm going gonna fucking watch all of
these things. And then, uh, I dunno,
six months later I'll forget most of it.
I'll probably combine a couple,
two or three wars.
I'll get drunk and I'll just start
spewing out information about Lincoln
speaking in a, he would Jima. All right.
Anyway, let's get on with the podcast.
Highly recommend that if you, uh,
if you get a chance, if you have seven
hours to kill, I highly recommend that
if you have chicken pox,
it'd be a great way to, uh,
forget about the itching
for a good seven hours. Um,
yeah.
What else? Oh, tonight. Oh, last night.
Okay.
This is weird because I'm
taping this on Sunday. Um,
right now I'm taping this Sunday
afternoon, New Orleans time and uh,
I'm actually really excited
obviously because, uh,
the season five, I guess the
second has of seasons, season five,
the breaking bad premiers tonight.
Did I start like 12 sentences there?
Let me try that again. These seasoned,
the second half of the season five
series premiere of breaking bad starts
tonight.
Okay.
Do you guys ever wonder why it never
became a game show host is cheesy as I am.
Or like ever like hosted the family
feud or was standing next to Billy Bush
[inaudible] like they have to read stuff.
Okay.
You know, I know I have the head to
be on. I don't have the hairline,
but I do have the head,
you know, I fuck it. Who gives
a shit anyways, breaking bad.
It's coming back tonight
and I can't fucking wait.
I thought there was only five episodes.
It's just fun. What? There's eight.
So I'm psyched about that.
And um, I've already,
I think I've already gotten past the
sadness that it's ending and I'm just
talking as a fan. Forget about
the fact that I used to, you know,
get in there every once in a while.
Um,
yeah,
I can't wait for this thing
to come out on box set and,
uh, and just go back and just go
through that whole thing again.
MMM.
A couple of months back,
I actually watched the first two
episodes of breaking bad and just seeing,
you know, Cranston's character, Walter
White has the hair and he's just meeting,
uh, Jesse for the first time. Do you
know, I heard, I don't know if this true,
but I heard that Jesse was actually,
that character was gonna.
They were gonna have him killed in the
first few, but he was such a good actor,
uh, Aaron Paul that they are, and
they liked the character so much.
I don't know if that's true.
I should stop fucking making up shit.
I think I remember reading this. Like
what, why would you do that bill?
Why would you,
it's one of the few bridges you can
actually cross in this business and now
you're going to burn it by
putting out misinformation.
What the fuck is wrong
with you? Um, anyways,
I was, I was somewhere at killing time.
Oh, yesterday when I was in Chicago.
Okay.
And I was a in the hotel and they had a
marathon on of those doomsday preppers
and uh,
they're all fucked.
Do you know why all those
doomsday preppers are fucked
is because they're loners.
They might survive some initial shit.
They might last a month,
they might last a year,
but they're just,
instead of ripping the bandaid off
like me and just getting fucking,
you know, bludgeoned to death
within the first 24 hours
or vaporized from something blowing up
that that's, that's my doom state plan.
My Dooms Day prepping that I do is that
I live in probably the most dangerous
city that you could possibly
live in as far as earthquakes,
as far as the water supply,
as far as the fucking inability
to get the fuck out of there.
I really should get a helicopter license
and tried to go on Ebay and buy some
fucking use chopper.
Cause other than that I'm fucked.
But there's,
there's a,
there's a piece that you gain from just
being completely fucked is you just
saying,
what am I going to do?
I'm fucked.
All right.
Oh, I get a great idea. I'm
going to sell a doomsday prepper,
um,
kit
for people who don't want to
prep and what it's going to be.
It's going to be a beautiful locket
that you where they'll have a mail once,
a little more masculine,
like put some spikes on it or some shit
for male or female and when you open it
up, there's one little cyanide
pill in there. There you go.
You just off yourself.
That's all it is collapsing.
There's fighting in the street. You just
pop it in there and that's it. It's over.
You know
you want to live in beyond dead body
patrol going out there with the fucking
scheme as gone,
having a barrier,
all those cuts before they
give out disease because
that's what you're going to
be doing if you survive.
If you're a low level human like
myself where you're really not bringing
anything to the table,
if they let you survive,
if they decide out of the
fucking glue to let you survive,
that's what you're going to be all that's
going to be your first fucking jobs.
Okay?
Other than getting naked and have him
throw the fucking lie all over here,
whatever they fucked Lyme, is that
what they throw it? Lie, lie Ma.
You got to get rid of the body lice,
your job,
you're going to go out there and some
sort of Tarzan fucking bikini bottoms with
that powdered sugar all over you.
And you're going to just start,
you're going to up,
it's gonna be yet.
So my suggestion is either get some
cyanide or learn how to use operate a
backhoe cause other than that,
if you survive,
you're going to be standing there with
a shovel getting a fucking sunburn that,
uh, the, the, the, the
modern world has never seen.
Okay.
Anyways, I'm watching this, this
doomsday prepper thing and uh,
they got all these guys doing this shit
and they got this one dude who's just,
you know, he's got like fucking
three years worth of shit.
He's got flat screen TVs,
got all his fucking stuff down.
So I love the flat screen TV.
That's hilarious to me.
Like it's the end of the world,
but somehow cable still exists.
Somehow somebody is at the head
of the cables, cables central,
wherever that is,
flipping the switch so you can see the
final eight episodes of breaking bad. Um,
despite the fast, everybody
connected with Hollywood is now gone.
Um,
yeah.
Except for Wesley Snipes. I'm sure
he's got a bunker somewhere. Um, yeah,
if you've got the Ballston and
I pigged the government taxes,
you definitely got you got,
you have a strategy in place
and plus just even if that shit,
even if he didn't take martial arts,
just the sword swinging alone,
that he had to learn the choreography
that would scare the fuck out of most
zombies and they turned
the other way. Right? Yeah.
MMM.
So he's got all of this stuff and
he's sitting there talking about he,
he's still afraid of the
Russians and a nuclear holocaust.
He's been prepping for 30 years because
that's basically what they used to scare
the shit out of us about. Um, I came
in in the tail end of it in the 70s,
and, uh, this guy was older than me,
so they psychologically fuck this guy
up so bad that he was now, you know,
stockpiling this hole in the ground.
And then he found out that,
uh,
recently declassified information said
that the Russians had detonated some
fucking, I dunno, 200 mega ton
fucking something or other,
but the biggest bomb ever detonated.
They did it and he realized
that he wasn't deep enough.
So he went out and he bought this big
steel fucking tube and the whole time he's
doing this,
this guy is like 200 pounds overweight.
Yeah.
And it's like, dude, you better,
you better deal with that first.
Like you,
you're going to drop up a fucking heart
attack before they drop a fucking bomb
on us. And he finally addressed
it. He says, you know,
I probably should get
myself in better shape.
Of course he was sitting down the entire
time and even with the tee shirt on,
the guy was so fucking fat, you could
tell that he was finished. But um,
so I actually liked the guy cause he
finally addressed the fact that he was out
of shape and needed to do something
about it. But towards the end,
there was this 15 year old
kid who since the age of 12,
um, maybe it was a little bit older, one
was 2008. That was five years ago. He's,
what's 17?
He was 12 one to 2008 a
banking collapse happened.
So he went on and he,
he internet and he started reading up
on banks and probably saw the conspiracy
theory that I did. And it scared the
fucking shit out of him as a 12 year old.
And this fucking kid has been like
scavenging slash stealing shit wherever he
can because he doesn't have any money.
And he has all these guns and he
has these fucking swords and shit.
He dresses in fatigues and stuff.
And his mother is just sitting
there going like, you know,
I always wanted a normal thought.
I don't know why he feels he has to
do this and that. And now he's got,
he's brought a friend into a fold and the,
and then they brought it a into the fold
and he brought a third person into the
fold. And it's literally like,
lady, Lady, did you see Colin?
Bye. All right. I'm not
saying this kid is like that,
but like what the fuck
are you doing? Her, her,
her big parental moment was
he's not allowed to go to
the gun range without her.
She goes there and let some practice in.
This fucking kid was great.
His spread was basically from,
you know,
one ventricle to the fucking
other. All right. This,
is there two ventricles or is that an AOL?
I don't fucking know.
I'll Google map the heart at
the end of this. Um, yeah,
he was basically hitting it
all center mass right around,
right around your fucking
heart. Right. And,
but then he goes home and he's got the
ammo when he has the guns in his fucking
bedroom. And um, you know, he's
like, I'm thankful Lou, uh,
grow up with guns.
He doesn't even
have a southern accent.
Why am I fucking trash in the south again?
Okay.
Hear this fucking awful haircut. He didn't
have a girlfriend. He's a fucking, he's,
he's going down this rabbit hole
and she's just letting them do it.
And, uh, I find it really disturbing.
I don't find it disturbing when like
I see those kids smiling and they have
rifles and their parents have
gotten them into hunting.
I know people out where I live
and when I lived in New York City,
they freak out about that stuff.
Um, really intolerant of it,
you know, as they eat a
fucking chicken burrito. Uh,
but I don't, I think you should know how
to hunt and do all that type of shit.
You know what? I didn't know
I could fucking kill. I could
kill a pig, a wild boar.
I would love to go out and do that.
Yeah.
Fucking shoot that day.
You know,
I want to hear it from the rednecks
out there. What am I in for?
Yeah.
If I miss and I think comes
up when we don't, they just
start fucking eaten. Yeah.
The pigs. Right. They fucking
eat anything. What I scare
them or what I look like.
One of those white
chocolate covered pretzels.
Okay.
They think my freckles was
salt. It'd be all over it. Um,
would it be okay? Can slips
in somebody, you know,
next time I do one of my
southern towards here.
Can you guys take me pig hunting and uh,
I want to fucking do it up.
I want to go Rambo style with a crossbow,
but I do want to have a backup Uzi.
And I know if you're a redneck,
I know you have a fucker newsy that's
been fucking handed down since the the
eighties.
Whenever the fuck who's came out before
the laws prevented you from getting them?
It's for while I'm hunting quail.
Okay.
Uh, it's just America. Um,
okay.
All right, let's get into some
questions for the week here. Uh,
I'll read the last couple of advertisers.
What don't I do that? All right,
here we go. He had a bad first quarter.
I did great in the second quarter.
Let's get out. We've got another 30
minutes. It's when this game, here we go.
Last couple legal zoom,
everybody.
Most Americans don't have a will.
But why you don't want government rules
dictating what happens to your property
and minor children. Do
you, so why procrastinate?
Most people say it's too expensive
or it's too time consuming.
My answer is legal zoom.com too expensive.
You're going to love legal zooms,
reasonable prices, too. Time consuming.
Most people finish the online process
and just 20 minutes and we're not talking
some fill in the blank bs form here.
Your will is state specific
and personalized based on
your, your information.
Best of all legal zoom has 12 years of
experience helping people with important
legal matters. Um, it's national.
Make a will month again this month,
so don't wait any longer.
Go to legal zoom.com today and
get 50% off your last will,
but this offer ends or get a living trust
and you will receive a pour over will
absolutely free. Um, to get your special
discount, be sure to enter burpee.
You are R and the referral
box at checkout for wills,
power of attorney trust and more.
Go to legal zoom.com legal
zoom can provide self-help, uh,
services at your specific direction
or connect you with an attorney,
but they are not a law firm. Law Firm.
God Dang it. I had it till the end.
All right, eva, you're screening calls,
closing deals and making money all while
lounging poolside in the summer sun.
Thanks to eat voice,
he voices a better way to connect with
your people that drive your business.
He voice will forward your
business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose. Wherever
you are, he voiced, we'll find you.
Um,
if you don't have time to take a call,
it's routed to your voicemail and you
can read it at your convenience as a text
message. Evil not only gives you
an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge the big
companies have over you right now.
That's a huge point right there. People,
I hope you were listening with he voice.
You can create the impairments of a
whole office building of departments.
When customers call you a
sales department, customer
support, tech support,
you name it, it's going to seem like
you have it and it works with any phone.
Even yourself. Hey, it's summer.
Don't be stuck in your office all day.
Free Yourself, uh, with a
free 30 day trial of he voice.
You can see what I'm talking about.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the
Promo code bill for your 30 day free
trial. That's he voiced.com promo
code bill, or go to the podcast page,
[inaudible] dot com and click on the
voice banner and now it's time for the
stairway to heaven of advertisers here.
The last and final one,
stamps.com everybody pretend you
have a wad of cash in your hand.
Now imagine throwing it in the trash.
That's exactly what you're doing when
you're leasing one of those expensive
postage meters for your, uh, for your
small business longterm commitments,
maintenance and reset fees.
Expensive ink. It's crazy.
I know a better way.
What is it?
stamps.com everybody with stamps.com you
get all the benefits of a postage meter
and more at a fraction of the cost.
Just use your own computer and printer
to get official US postage for any
envelope.
And he packaged any class of mail plus
no more time consuming trips to the post
office. Everything you would
do with the post office,
you can do it right now from your own
desk with stamps.com I use stamps.com to
send out whatever the hell I'm selling
that week after my shows. Tee shirts,
posters, DVDs, whatever you want. Um,
and if I can use it,
you can use it because I am a moron and
I have the co a high school transcript
to prove it right now. Use My last
name, birth for this special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus offer and
includes a digital scale and up to $55
free postage. Dale you waiting
for go to stamps.com right now.
Before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the
page homepage. Excuse me, and typing bur
bur that stamps.com enter birth are right.
There you go.
There you go. Into the wild
blue yonder. All right,
let's get into the uh, the rates
for this week. Italy. Hey Belle.
You mentioned a couple of weeks ago that
you were thinking about going to Italy
and you wanted some advice about
where to go. My lady is Italian,
so I've been there a bunch of times.
Here's the deal.
First you should decide if you
want to see the north or the south.
The North is more industrialized with
lots of interest in interesting cities.
Yeah. And San Marino too. All right.
Isn't that where the blue bloods day a
good food and as a more vibrant urban
feel. The South is more country style
with good weather and beautiful nature.
I think I kind of liked that.
You could think of it being very roughly
like the difference between New England
and the south back of the states.
And the winner of the north will be
pretty cold and the south will be a little
more ball. Me, they both are the shit.
All right, cool. Ah, where's Rome?
Rome's like right in the middle.
I got to get to know that type of stuff.
Okay.
I can't wait to go.
Um,
and that's what I'm going to do
right before my a European tour.
Yeah.
Uh, is I've got to go to Italy for a
couple of days, like two, three days.
Why the fuck wouldn't you if you're
going to be over there anyways,
I'll get acclimated to the time,
the time change while eating some of
the best food on the planet. I mean,
my two favorite kinds of food
is a Italian and Japanese.
Those are my two favorites.
Okay.
I love them both fucking delish.
Um,
so I got to figure out where I'm going
to go on because I only have three days.
Okay.
I don't want to go there and
try and do a bunch of things.
Okay.
I think it just want to go there
and eat a big into stadiums.
Maybe I would see the Roman Colosseum,
but uh,
okay.
I think I just want to, um, I
don't know what I want to do.
I just want to eat some fucking just
great place and tastes really clean food
with like what I show respect
about Italian. Just how,
how much they give a shit about
the food making process. You know,
I've told the shit the
foist just to no more ice,
no more Italian guys back in the day when
I was living in Boston and I swear to
God they would watch,
we make a meal and it would
like be upsetting them and
eventually they just have
to take over, be like, just,
just, just get out of here.
Like they would watch you fucking up
a piece of meat. It would literally,
it would,
it would owed upset them.
Okay.
You know, so you gotta respect
it. All right, here we go.
Salads. Oh by the way, that's
another great part in the, the,
the Ken Burns documentary is um,
okay.
You know, I always saw Mussolini
given the speeches. Yeah. Oh,
he's got one great one. When he's, he
keeps doing this thing with his hand like,
Hey, let them have Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. Like he's just fucking talking shit.
Like Hitler makes me want to speak German
and Mussolini makes me want to speak
Italian. Just watching those speeches,
watch it. Hitler's screaming and yelling
like, you know, we used to be quiet,
no sock up second a shit. I mean,
is that what he's saying?
I want to know what the fuck is he
yelling about and Mussolini that look at
confidence on his face. I just want to
hear what the fuck he's talking about.
I'm sure this transcriptions,
but it's,
it's gotta be better if you
actually know the language. Um,
and I got that fucking Irish thing where
I got to do everything the hard way. Um,
so all I would ever see was him a
Mussolini given the speeches and then him
fucking hanging by the meat,
hook him with his fucking girlfriend.
Okay.
MMM. And I always wonder
what the hell had happened.
And I didn't know that
he had gotten captured
and then the Nazis came in and freedom.
Yeah,
you don't like the fucking expendables
Assam Shit. Is that a right reference?
I never saw one of those movies, but that
seemed like they what they were doing,
like they will rescue the people and uh,
okay.
And then he got,
he got caught again and he tried
to talk his way out of it again.
And his last words were,
was basically saying no,
like, no, no, no. It's fucking Christ.
What a fucking way to go out.
Yeah,
it, I've been talking about that
in my act. It's just that guy,
like a year's time he
went from just like being,
having a boy band fame and everybody's
screaming and throwing bras at him and
shit to be like on his
knees. Like keep fucking,
they killed him, man. His woman, I
love it too. It was his mistress,
I believe is what they call,
I don't fucking remember.
I remember you starting to forget the
shit and then they brought him into town
and everybody was kicking
him and dig his face. Just,
they just kicked the shit out of his face
and this spitting on him and they hung
up by a meat hook.
Okay.
It's like what happened? You know,
you think it's bad to be like,
you know, in, in old town, try
being a fucking dictator, man. It's,
it's brutal.
It just does.
That's why they never have a behind the
music for dictators because, you know,
how would it, for the most part, I would
fucking ends. You don't end, you know,
you're not lying in bed.
Yeah.
You know, going through some
fucking Buddhist, this is
the death process. You know,
where they teach you how to die peacefully
and you're surrounded by fucking
loved ones or whatever.
This is the exact opposite of that shit.
Okay.
Hitler blew his brains out.
What's his face?
Okay.
Mostly Lady. I just told you
what the fuck happened to him.
Sudan will say they dragged
him out of a fucking hole.
He went out like a gangsta though, man.
That Jesus Christ, he refused the hood.
We put the rope around his neck and
he was getting heckled.
This is his shit. Like when
people talk about, you know,
when they go and they look at comics
getting heckled and taken on the crowd,
he has to have the best one for,
for dictators.
He was standing there and he's getting
heckled and he's giving him shit right
back with a fucking rope around his neck.
He got to respect that math.
I would have been like Muesli
and me trying to fucking
wriggle my fed out of it.
I definitely would have taken the hood.
Um,
who else does that get that?
The fatty over there in a
little fat boy in Korea.
I wonder how he died.
He's probably watching like little
house on the prairie or something.
He was a weird guy.
It was in the movies and shit.
He actually, he lived, it's very few that
actually get to make, make it that far.
You know,
they get to continue where it's like
actors who get to continue working on into
their seventies and still doing like
Oscar winning work. It's very difficult.
Most people fall by the wayside. All
right bill, we get it. Okay. All right.
You know I'm into that shit.
Alright, salads. Hey Bill.
I would like to get into eating
more salads, but I'm only 20.
And what the fuck do I know about salads
do I didn't know shit about salads.
I wish I started eating salads when I was
20. I wouldn't have this fucking mess.
Jesus Christ and it's
pasty. It's even worse. Uh,
should I get into spinach? Some good old
iceberg lettuce. What do I put in Salad?
What's the point of making a salad?
If I just cover with ranch dressing
and put a bunch of Bacon on it,
I'm not even sure what Balsamic
vinegarette is. Is a boiled egg.
A good thing to put in is appreciated.
Gotta be a Dick here and say hi. Hi.
Blackhawks won while you want.
You get the fucking brag about it.
You can't listen.
I don't know shit about nutrition.
I'm just starting to learn about it.
I know iceberg lettuce is like 90% water.
I think a spinach is good shit.
I like that.
I like a regular um,
kales awesome.
And um,
yeah,
don't go through all the crappy eating
that shit and then put a bunch of
dressing on it cause you know,
you're adding all those extra calories,
I guess Balsamic vinegarette this
is all shit that I've overheard.
I heard that that's the healthier one.
But even then I try to avoid drowning.
And uh, what's great about is
when you start eating them,
you start craving them and that becomes
one meal a day. And that's just, you know,
you got to start looking at like a steak
and cheese sandwich or something like
that. A pizza. That's just, it's
just a plate full of setups.
You know,
I fucking hate going to the gym.
I like going to the gym
cause I want to look good.
I hate going to the gym
cause I fucking have to go,
which is what I'm doing right
now, which sucks, you know,
you know what's another bad one is when
you fucking sitting up in bed like I am
and you'll hold your iPhone up to you
and you get the reflection of like,
you're fucking nine Chin's
start to get that Pelican
neck. Ah. Anyways,
so, um, there's a bunch of recipes out
there. You can find it, but I would, I,
I'd stay away from iceberg.
That's stinks. Romaine is like,
that's like halfway decent.
All right. Iceberg lettuce.
They're like the,
uh,
yeah.
I Dunno. What will you want? You
want to go sports on this one?
We'll go sports and I'm not talking
about what they're gonna do this year,
what they did last year. I would just
say what they've done in my lifetime.
All right. Iceberg lettuce is like
the fucking Detroit lions. Uh,
even though they're good now, they weren't
then. So that's probably a bad example.
The Cleveland browns of lettuce,
sorry everybody in Cleveland.
Although I did promote your city and I
saw a lot of fucking knock construction
going on there.
A romaine lettuce is like dead fucking
team that every once in a while makes the
playoffs but never fucking wins it there.
That's like the Falcons of lettuce.
Um, and then you get into a
rural girl loves the cowboys.
Kale, I would say is the
40. Niners and uh, I dunno,
I dunno.
Maybe I should have said the packers
and Steelers or the Steelers and packers
packers are the most successful.
So I'd say the Kale,
I'd say Steelers not just shut
the fuck up. Okay. A Russian guy.
Outwits banks. Oh, I
like this one already.
Hey Bill thought you might enjoy reading
this article about a Russian man who
outwit it, a bank by writing his own
terms into their credit card contract.
Jesus Christ. That's fucking
phenomenal. I hadn't held it.
That's like beaten.
Bruce Lee had karate or
Kung Fu a Jean funky,
whatever the fuck he did article.
Here we go.
The idea of beating the banks at their
own game may seem like a rich joke,
but to me, tree, uh,
Gara Cove, a Gar cove,
I don't know, 42 year old Russian man
sounds like he plays for the Redwings,
doesn't hae a 42 year old Russian
man may have managed to do it.
Unhappy with the terms of the,
of an unsolicited credit card offer he
received from an online bank tin cough
credit system at Gar cough.
Sorry.
If you're listening and I'm butchering
this story. If you have Russian descent,
uh,
he scanned the document,
wrote in his own terms and
sent it through the bank,
approved the contract without
reading the amended fine print,
unwittingly agreeing
to a 0% interest rate,
unlimited credit and no fees as well as
a stipulation that the banks at the bank
pay steep fines for changing
or canceling the contract.
Okay.
The bank has so much money, they'll
be able to get around this. But what,
that's fucking genius.
What a hero. A Garco.
I've used the card for two years,
but the bank ultimately it
and sued a Gar car for $1,363.
The bank said he owed them charges,
interest, and late payment fees.
A court ruled that because of the no fee,
no interest stipulation to
guard cough had written in,
he owed only his unpaid $575 balance.
Look at this two minutes left in the
game. People, are you going to win this?
A what?
A God carve is now suing the bank for
$727,000 for not honoring the contract's
term.
And the bank is hollering fraud.
They signed the documents without looking.
They said what used what?
Usually they said to me,
what?
Usually their borrowers saying
court, we've, we've not read it.
A golf club's lawyer said, uh,
the shoe's on the other foot now.
Sorry, I really butchered their
ending of that reading so well,
I got to pay attention to that.
Well, they'll settle out of court.
I Dunno, man. That's,
that's a hard, I mean,
the fact that you got to just
got out of paying the fees.
I gotta put this in my,
uh, my computer here.
I want to pay attention to a Gar cough.
Okay.
Russia
bank case
Ak. So it's still at that point. Hey,
anybody in Russia listen to this thing.
Can You keep,
please keep me abreast of this.
I want to see if he gets any
of that. $727,000. All right.
I want to do a little pre game
analysis here. I'll tell you right now,
I gotta tell Ya,
if I'm the bank I got to be taken out of,
we ended up in this situation,
I would actually guess that they're
not gonna pay any of that. Um,
they probably got enough politicians
and judges in their pockets. I mean,
it's corrupt enough over here.
I can't imagine what the fuck it's
like over there. No offense, but, uh,
it is what it is. Um, yeah.
If anybody I know Estonia,
Latvia, get close enough, you can
pay attention, they'll let me know.
I'd appreciate it. Lithuania, the Ukraine,
Belarus, look at me. I've learned some
shit. Uh, I'm an attention whore. Bill.
Bill Burke Marshall.
I'm a 16 year old guy and I've recently
come to terms with the fact that I love
attention. In most instances, this
would not be too big of a deal. I mean,
look at you. You made a career out
of it. Hey listen, you fucking cunt.
Just cause you find
out that you're a dick.
You don't get to rub up against
me and get your stink on me.
Okay?
You know? Did I say I didn't like
fucking attention? You asshole.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
You know I was actually
going to compliment you with
the fact that you actually
could.
You could step outside yourself and see
something that could potentially be a
floor. Wanting attention is not a bad
thing. It's all how you do it, you know?
All right, here we go. I
constantly sit in class loudly,
cracking jokes and can usually
get the whole class laughing.
Plus I don't have to worry about the
teachers yelling at me because I'm such a
manipulated,
manipulative son of a bitch that I
have ensured that they all liked me.
Here's the problem. My
friends hate it. All right?
This has taken a different turn here.
The jokes I make with them are far
different. I actually think they're funny.
You see the jokes I make to the whole
class or Shitty hacky, cheap, cheesy,
douchey jokes,
targeting a group laugh.
The jokes I make with my friends
are normally riffing on something.
They might actually be creative.
Okay.
Oh, all right. So you kind of,
when you're with your friends,
you're actually a comic's comic,
but when you're in front of
the crowd, you, you're, you're,
you're playing to the masses. Well,
you've got to pick a road here, son.
Um, or maybe it don't,
I mean it's not you,
you're trying to be a
comedian or maybe you are,
if you're going to be a comedian,
I would try to make the crowd laugh at
the jokes to make your friends left.
All right, here we go. Now.
Now I know the simple solution seems
to be stopped being a class clown,
but I just loved the attention.
I'm so emotionally undeveloped that
I craved the CRAs class approval and
attention. Dude, you're not
emotionally undeveloped.
This is unbelievable that you have this
sort of a knowledge of self. It's 16.
I certainly didn't what you know at 16
I don't think I knew until I was 36 so
you're, you're, you're in a,
okay,
you're in a good situation. Here he goes,
I love being the center of the class,
making everyone laugh to spice, knowing
that I'm being fake and not myself.
Yeah.
What should I do?
Should I stop cracking the shit jokes
in class or should I tell my friends to
get over it and keep being that guy?
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself. Ah,
first of all, I don't know what the
fuck your friends have a problem with.
I mean, how bad are these
jokes? Just say and, and
yeah,
you're basically what you're doing
is in class. Sounds like the first,
I dunno, three to six, seven,
eight years of being a standup comedian
were once you figure out how to make the,
uh, the crowd laugh, you then
try to be like, well, I want to,
okay,
I want to be like, say what? I
really want to talk about up here.
Basically find your voice. So, um,
I don't think that you should make
a change because of your friends.
I think you should make a change because
you want to make the change, you know,
when that makes sense. If you like
the attention and that type of shit,
who gives a fuck?
Okay.
But, uh, if you want to take your
class clown or to the next level,
I would go with some of
the more creative stuff.
You don't have to always go with a shit
joke, but I have to commend you that you,
when I used to be a class clown,
I would always get in trouble
and the teachers didn't like me.
So the fact that he able to
do that is great. And uh,
I think you're going to be real
successful in like in life.
You could do anything.
Politics Show business sales.
Okay.
If you like, if you could
actually talk to a crowd that,
that really puts you ahead of the game, I
would think. All right. He also says, ps,
as a Blackhawks fan,
I would just like to personally thank
Boston fans for being so classy,
respectful,
and dare I say Saint Lake St
like from the bottom of my hat,
my black cock hard. I would like to
personally thank each and every Bruin fan.
You were all models of fandom.
Thank you for fucking mocking that.
Um, or just trying to rub it in.
I don't give a shit at this point.
That seemed like years ago and
we just want a cup, so I'm good.
So congratulations to you,
sir.
Good luck with trying to find your
voice as a class clown. All right.
God Damn ex-girlfriend.
Dare Billy boy.
Um, your podcast is killer, man. Thanks.
Well thank you. I appreciate that.
And he says, I'm writing you to get some
insight on my ex girlfriend situation.
About six months ago, my ex dump my
ass and totally crushed my heart.
That's the worst. Did you got
to go throw it though? Uh,
he says I was fucked up for a while,
but it took some of your advice and
focused on improving my own shit.
I never called her texts
or a did any asshole.
It's for six months. A couple
of months ago, she texts me, ah,
fuck.
And I know it.
I know it now without reading
this thing she's texted you now.
Either she legitimately wants
to get back together with you,
which if you still love her,
that would be a good thing or
whatever the fuck she,
whatever path life path she went down
over the last six months has hit a hard,
is it a bump in the road and maybe she's
having second thoughts or maybe she's
completely evil and she's like,
wow, he just never called me again.
Why don't I call him up in mind?
Fuck them.
Those are my three guests on the,
uh,
the cont genie lamp player.
All right? So she texted me,
she wanted to know what I've
been up to and how I was doing.
She also wanted to know why I unfriended
her on Facebook. And he writes,
why do you think you'd dump cunt
that, wait a minute, did you
unfriend her because of my advice?
Did you do that on your own?
That's a great thing. You got,
you got to get cut the cancer out.
You can't be watching
what the fuck she's doing.
All you're doing is prolonging that
pain in your heart. You got to watch,
I'm telling you,
if you gotta,
you gotta cut off all contact and
then you got to go Chris Bosh.
We just got to drop to your knees a
couple of times a day and cry it out.
Don't be afraid to fucking do that and
I wouldn't do it in front of a bunch of
men, but you know, do it
on your own like as a man.
You have to understand that the reason
why you're able to cry is because you
supposed to because if you don't,
you keep it in your chest and it becomes,
and then you yell at your kids.
All right.
I resisted the urge to tell her to go
fuck herself and kept my responsible,
my responses. Cool and casual. Dude,
you are on the road to a post breakup
blow job. That's where you are right now.
Let's see if you keep the car on the road.
Here's my question.
How the fuck do broads know when you are
finally getting over them and that they
should get ahold of you and
make you feel like shit again.
Also d say I know it.
Yeah.
Also,
do you think it's a dick move to get a
hold of an x if you're the one who dumped
then when they haven't gotten a hold
of you since the breakup. Finally,
how do you think I should
handle this going forward? Um,
well you know what? You, you basically,
you learned one of life's tough lessons.
Is that a
yeah,
my amino something.
I might be being a dick here.
Like baby got guys do this shit too.
All right guys do do this shit too.
That you got those guys who they break
up with a girl but then they keep her in,
in, they try to like hold onto
her so no one else can fucker.
You know guys who do that shit.
So this is really like I'm
being a sexist more on as usual.
MMM.
I'm coming from the male perspective.
That's all I got. All right.
Trying to show a little empathy here.
Um, how do they know? I don't know,
but they're great at it.
So rather than trying to figure it out
because I don't know that you can as a
guy,
just respect that they have that ability.
All right.
Um,
you might want to consider changing
your cell phone number so she can't text
slash mind fuck you again.
MMM.
What if it is the fucking worst? They
just the fucking worst in that situation,
dude. You just, you got
to walk away from a man.
So I can't remember what
the fuck you asked me.
I'm going through all the breakups
I've been through mentally right now.
MMM.
All right.
So the first thing you said is how the
fuck do broads know when you finally over
them, I don't know, change your cell
phone number is my solution. Um,
also,
do you think it's a dick move to get
ahold of an x if you have no intention of
getting back with them? Yes, I do.
And you have to accept the guilty.
You feel that you broke somebody's
heart and you have to own that.
You can't like calling, just calling
to make sure you're doing okay.
You're not helping that other person.
If you have no intent,
you're giving them a half a second,
a hope and then you know,
you're just, you're, you're, you're
ruining them. You gotta let them go.
Um, and lastly, how do you think I
should handle this going forward?
Yeah. I would say don't
respond to her texts or uh,
even that,
just her texting you and seeing your name
and knowing that she's thinking about
you and your heart's still going to be
like, well, maybe, maybe two minutes.
You can night together. I would just
change the number. Start over again.
Go Bill Bixby. Get a
backpack. Walk out of town.
Who Do go down the fucking street.
Um,
start working out. Get some new women
in your life. That's another thing.
Go out there and go hit kid on
something he thinks out of your league.
Gives a shit.
Go have a good time.
I'm hitting on a girl that's odd.
That's so called rd or league is like
playing a sport against people who are
better than you. It makes you
better it up. She's game. All right.
So then when you, you play
against somebody who's only
little out of your league,
your actually, you used to play
and beyond and you're not nervous.
You used to that speed, you
know? Does that make any
fucking sense? I hope it does.
Anyways, that is the, uh, the podcast
for this week. Everybody. Thank you.
As always for everybody who's contributed
with the questions and everything that
really is the last half of
this podcast every week. MMM.
And also, I forgot to mention
that, uh, the last couple of weeks,
if you'd like to support this podcast,
a very easy way is if you plan on buying
on some something on amazon.com just go
to billboard.com first click
on the podcast page and
click on the Amazon banner
that we have that'll take you right to
Amazon and you don't have to do shit
after that.
It doesn't change the prices of anything.
They kicked me a percentage of the
sale for driving traffic their way.
I take a percentage of that,
send it to the wounded warriors project.
So it's a two for one as far as
supporting me and supporting the wounded
warriors project and also hard
copy versions of my DVD, uh,
of my standup special,
sorry,
DVD copies are available on my website
and also available for download,
um, for five bucks. And it's uh,
the, you people are all the same.
So people have asked me when
I'm doing another special,
I've begun talks about planning about
doing one in the first half of next year.
I basically I do them every other year.
Um,
as basically outworks I
spend one year having fun,
right.
And a new hour and then I spend the next
year fine tuning it and then when I'm
done with that, then I shoot it. That's
basically a, that's basically what I do.
And uh, that's the formula it's been
working for me, so I'm sticking with it.
And then also people in Scotland
had been asking me about my,
am I still doing Scotland
because they didn't see a date.
I am definitely doing a date. Things got
moved around. I do two shows in London.
I'm still doing one in Scotland.
Um,
it's going to be at this theater,
I forget the name of it,
but I'm somewhere around the fourth of
the 5th of December or something like
that. But, uh,
hopefully at some point this week I'm
going to get an official date and I'm
going to tweet about it.
I will Facebook about it and I
will podcast about it next week.
And a thank you to everybody over
there who's been buying up the tickets.
It starting off really strong and,
uh, somebody actually sent me a,
um, for the, uh,
the advertisement in Stockholm and it was
really cool. It was other than my name,
obviously, if it's all written and
fucking Swedish and shit, and it's just a,
it's the coolest fucking thing
ever that there's people in an,
on the other side of the world speaking
a different language and they're writing
about a show that you gotta
go up there and go, do, you
know, he's fucking awesome.
So anyways, I'm really
excited about that. And, uh,
all the shit that I have coming up. Uh,
oh, by the way, if you're in into a,
if you're not into motorcycle
racing or you'd like to get into it,
they got one of their grand prixs,
I think it's in Indianapolis or something,
somewhere in the states this
weekend coming up on, uh,
August 18th,
I believe.
I'm actually going to watch it now
that I got a motorcycle license be,
I watched that documentary on Netflix
about all those motorcycle races,
races and that type of shit. It's just
fucking the balls that that takes.
It's like you weren't
in a formula one car,
except you don't have
a roll cage around you.
It's unfucking real the
balls of that takes.
So I'm hopefully going to have
time to watch it next Sunday.
I'm definitely gonna try to find
a buy out here. And once again,
thanks to everybody in New Orleans, been
having a great time coming around town,
going to the open mics, doing
the, uh, doing the standup shows,
been getting a wonderful reception.
And I've been trying a lot of new stuff.
So I'm having a ball down here.
I'm going to be down here for another
week and a half and then I'm back up.
Where the hell do I go? I go up to
Connecticut to do the MGM and then I do,
I think the University of Cincinnati,
and then I'm back out to la and that's
the deal. Everybody, that's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great week and I'll see you later.